pro b c'est important de revenir sur les
facultés affaiblies au volant ce matin
parce que les règles vont changer dès
mardi donc juste avant la grosse période
des fêtes
sachez le souvent consommation d'alcool
et période des fêtes ça va ensemble il
ya les rouges bien sûr on vous le
rappelle
mais ces règles là qui vont changer
elle risque d'être rapidement contestée
j'en parle ce matin avec m alexandre
morel bonjour avec morel alors la grande
affaire là dedans c'est le le fait que
les policiers sans motif raisonnable
vont pouvoir faire passer un alcootest
le conducteur un alcootest en bord de
route effectivement cependant il va y
avoir certaines prédispositions pour
qu'il puisse agir ainsi c'est à dire
qu'ils agissent légalement dans le cadre
de leurs fonctions et qu'ils aient en
leur possession l'appareil de détection
approuvé par exemple on ne pourrait pas
intercepté un conducteur puis demander
un autre policier d'apporter l'appareil
les votre alors que ce soit en notre
possession c'est donc sans croire
nécessairement que la personne a
consommé de l'alcool
ça va être possible pour un policier
d'intervenir comme ça tu te fais sans
même que de soupçons
qu'est ce que vous en pensez ça va poser
certains défis au niveau de la légalité
de cette disposition en vertu de la
charte parce qu'il faut penser qu'une
feu que l'imposition d'un alcootest
c'est peu intrusif mais ça demeure une
fouille corporelle donc évidemment c'est
prévu au niveau de la charte et il va
falloir que que cette disposition n'a
pas souhaité des tribunaux à savoir s'il
est légal scellés permise par la chatte
les ministes la sécurité publique rh
couderc lui
10 en fait que ça déjà permis en
australie notamment en irlande également
de réduire le nombre de décès sur les
routes donc trouve ça tout à fait
justifié mais est-ce que c'était
nécessaire dans le contexte du droit
canadien quand on sait qu'avant même
cette disposition las les soupçons
étaient très basses échec il ya une
odeur d'alcool ou une admission de
consommation d'alcool pour qu'on soit
autorisé à effectuer ce test
en fait il si on regarde les images mais
je m'adonne à regarder les statistiques
des décès au niveau des routes là si on
regarde depuis 2006 on est rendus on a
réduit de moitié déjà alors est ce que
cette mesure est nécessaire parce
qu'elle est souhaitable puisque c'est la
taille minimale de la vie privée des
gens l'autre règle qui va changer
maître morel c'est le fait en fait que
une personne qui peut être en deçà du
seuil et une en fait du point 08
lorsqu'il subit la côte est dans sa
voiture mais qu' une heure ou deux plus
tard se retrouve au poste de police et
leur passe à côté cela est au dessus
donc cette modification la va faire en
sorte qu'ils puissent quand même être
arrêtés et qu'ils puissent être
condamnés effectivement ce qui c'est une
défense qui était faisable dans certains
cas ou l'alcoolémie était relativement à
près de 80 mg et ont spécifiquement la
loi va empêcher de faire sa défense l'a
donc effectivement il ya une défense qui
vient de disparaître en plus de lire et
des règles ça reste relative est ce que
vous attendez à une vente des recours
judiciaires je te fais ce sujet là tout
à fait mais c'est des choses qui vont
être vivement contesté par les avocats
de la défense parce qu'il ya certaines
dispositions au niveau de la culpabilité
qui vont poser problème d'autres au
niveau des droits et libertés le haut
niveau de la charte qui vont être à
contester également est-ce que ça risque
d'engorger c'est un judiciaire pensez
vous que les policiers vont vont abuser
faut faire confiance aux faux phare
confiance au jugement des policiers mais
effectivement ça pourrait être
générateur d'abus évidemment des avocats
de la défense vont être là pour défendre
les accusés dans ce cas merci beaucoup
d'avoir été là c'est bien